Let's go to our caller from the 7 0 4 area
code who's calling today from 7 0 4.
Is I mean.
Yeah.
Hey, David, I'm very sympathetic to the argument
you provide on behalf of light.
The reason I can't personally bring myself
to voting for him is because it seems to me
to be very just physically, mentally fatigued.
There are moments during his campaigns, debates,
interviews, rallies, whatever it might be,
or he seems kind of confused.
And I was wondering if you just feel that
it's better to have some kind of draft.
I hear people mention the possibility of a
Democratic draft.
So your opinion on that?
I think it's insanely unlikely that that would.
You mean like drafting some other candidate?
Yeah, like of all places.
The National was just put out a publication
of drafting Cuomo.
Yeah.
I suddenly feel about overall.
Honestly, he would probably be a better pick
because I don't know if biting can exactly
compete against Trump.
It could be any center left candidate.
It's just bite.
It doesn't seem to be mentally and physically
up to the task.
Yeah.
Listen.
On balance.
If you said to me in a vacuum.
Would I prefer Cuomo or Biden?
I probably go with Cuomo for it for a few
different reasons.
The thing about, you know, the Biden dementia
stuff and the physical health stuff.
I mean, Trump's an incredibly obese 73 year
old who clearly seems to be suffering from
cognitive decline as well.
So if we even if we grant that this is like
some kind of dementia race, which I don't
actually think from from the things I've read
is the case.
But even if we grant that, I'd still rather
it be Biden, because if something happens
to Trump, it's Penns.
If something happens to Biden, it'll be somebody
much better than Pense or Trump.
So.
So it's I actually think that we I don't have
the power to say we're replacing Biden with
somebody else.
All I have the power to do is to evaluate
which of these two two people do I prefer.
Even granting the worst possible dementia
theory that anybody has.
I still prefer Biden over Trump.
I mean, that's that's the that's the reality.
Call it an unfortunate one or not, but that's
the reality.
Right.
Well, that's my one saving grace in terms
of being a candidate that he has like a very
solid V.P. candidate just in case.
It's just one of those things where, you know,
Trump is worse than Biden in many ways.
It just it's just that in terms of like competitive
debate, those two going at it side to side,
it seems like Biden would just be just slower
and he wouldn't necessarily be able to keep
up with a lot of the, you know, pettier insults
that Trump would levy.
Adam.
I can see I can see how you may say that.
Here's the only thing I'll say in advance
of the Bernie Biden debate.
You had a lot of people sort of counting on,
hoping for and expecting Biden to implode
so violently and embarrassingly that the primary
would instantly flip to Bernie Sanders.
And it didn't happen.
It was just sort of like a pretty uneventful
debate.
And in most cases, I also think that people
expecting this brutal implosion between Biden
and Trump probably also will be underwhelmed.
Now, that doesn't mean Biden is going to crush
these debates.
I'm not saying that.
But if you're counting on this implosion that
people were also counting on in the Bernie
debate, I probably wouldn't hold my breath
for that.
Well, I hope you're right.
Anyway, love the Shellman and things taking
my call.
All right.
Thank you.
Appreciate hearing from you very, very much.
That will do it for calls today.
We are going to go to a break.
Sorry I wasn't able to get to everyone, but
we did hear from some great, great people.
We will take calls again and I will hear from
you next.